oh hey hey hi hi welcome to the monitor
oh hello did my hands disappear hey
welcome to the monitor hi okay so this
is a really good week for comedy I check
it later don't worry about it this is
weird and there's a lot of naughty bits
I need to start wetting the bed when I'm
in my 30s a decapitated head of her
zombie boyfriend sounds good in most
bizarre way possible giant injection of
foul mouth stuffed animal am I really
that boring my virgin ears are burning I
exist in strange machine other world but
am I doing wrong bizarre sex metaphors I
need to be punished pick it out then
pick it up pack it up pack it in let me
begin with the magic of television
basically having your creativity
absolutely eviscerated and having your
dreams torn out of your chest I'm sorry
I'm gonna go wash my mouth out with soap
hello mental abilities be playing and
eventually you'll be fired and I
apologize for that we're here now the
theater the cinema does that sound good
churu bukh idiot thank you now why did I
thank you I beseech you I'm gonna go in
here get a drink and try not to get my
app kicked a post-operative transsexual
with some very demonic tone and he's got
an axe employment enjoyment summerslam
grilled jam fun splosion i love sax I
love saxophone dressing up like some
sort of an insect and engaging some sort
of active low oh I'm fine thanks for not
asking this creamy digital world of ours
selfish jackasses who are friends
wreaking havoc on the lives of those
around them music time let's talk about
this book that just magically appears
from my lap double shot uh-uh am I
achieving nirvana we're trying to
broaden your mind